thank you click friends family
ladies and gentlemen members of the
Academy thank you let me tell you a
little about myself as an actor I've
played more bandits thieves killers
warlords molesters and mafiosi that you
couldn't shake a stick at
I'm coming as a civilian I collect
antique clocks tell endless stories of
my days as a medic in World War two
watch every tennis match live for my
family
daily mail run the dishwasher take
pictures of faces in the bark of trees
i I really have a prawn song for a man
named Josh growling growling there he is
speaking of male sometimes I receive the
most bizarre correspondence ranging from
an Englishman looking for help
funding his mother's latest heart
operation to last year's letter from the
Pope really gushing up to me for his
favorite film was the Magnificent Seven
I couldn't understand that I kept
killing people in there and why not drop
by for a visit
the next time I'm in Rome I didn't
realize I had friends on such high
places
I did I didn't even know I was joining
the Academy for Christ's sake on a more
serious note I'm deeply moved by this
honor your recognition of my artistry
makes something very dear to me I don't
have to live I live to act I have looked
one last story to tell two young men
were planning a gift for their elderly
father's birthday so they decided to
hire and send out send over a hooker
the during negotiations she asks how old
is the birthday boy oh he's a he's in
his 90s Oh easy she said I could I can
handle him easy so she goes over to the
old man's house knocks on his door the
old man opens his and opens it and says
yes what is it
so she smiles and says I'm here to give
you super sex and there's a slight pause
and he says all right I'll take the soup
you
you